great steel level larceny from a
grünerløkka drags the defender in the
test calm and nice lob over the top
right there that's synergy right there
[Applause]
you've deflected retrieved by Luo man
the basketball right there you look at
Kawhi Leonard nice little hesitation
there you see the line he has not
disappointed in his flipper debut here
is a sledgehammer follows let him
operate in this area where he's very
good nice spin off spin I caught the
spin cycle and this dude is so good I
mean that was a foul by the way but
guess what he said y'all gonna fouled me
here we go see I come leaves it in with
the right hand
[Applause]
[Music]
finish inside with this lineup they're
just showing you a lot of respect and
everybody else's own enough see outcomes
coming down but how about this block
shot right here by montrezl continuing
to pursue and it's F matchup with a
point guard this is just big time effort
play right here come on
[Applause]
the saying defense to offense clipper
fans that's what you going to see all
year long
flopping that ball Clippers by one
[Music]
McGruder to montrezl
Telegraph that pass Beverly in the
corner Lou on the move
trans-time van Damme the Clippers lead
by to understanding that he only had a
second and a half to go he had to get it
up on the rim Lou Williams and there was
treads on the weak side forcing his way
inside to keep it alive 26 points from
montrezl harrell off the bench scratch
that make it 24 in the biggest bucket of
a game
that candles on the cake Kawhi Leonard
with 31 each year for Doc Rivers with
617 to play a nice ovation more horsemen
for the Clippers montrezl harrell Lou
Williams off the bench 23 and 22 but in
the third round except that when you set
the screen you play in selfish you
either have the corners open or you have
the strong finish inside now so skill
but more importantly the Wizards have
the worst defensive Malik
[Applause]
okay that's a to morphine
like to laugh also
can't let Marcus more senior gifts to
his to the middle
[Applause]
Larry Bird shot that he made back in the
mid 80s from behind the backboard I
don't think they counted that basket
does he have one more trick up his
sleeve
the rudder is good
and in this one here they took away two
jump shot nice teardrop right beer going
right home and stuff nasty bucket
Leonard
[Applause]
position right here for the Clippers
[Applause]
why has 34 an aggressive
the football
the wide nose if he comes off a screen
they're double-teaming so turn down the
screen and go dunk on whoever's in the
paint that was a big-time play by
big-time player Brian I'll tell you once
in a while he's being unselfish right
away he gets to basketball the big man
needs to run a veces ooh blocker goes in
all my goodness baptized mr. Collins
Sexton right here the quick jab Brandon
Knight from the initial possession lost
his footing and Kawhi Leonard calibrated
that move where he gets around Center
Sonny Smith has his three block by Kawhi
my goodness hurry for one and then
blocks the shot and then gets out and
one dunk the basketball on Luca Dante I
mean what a couple plays right there by
Kawhi Leonard
I mean nice finish he comes away with
recon number four
Clippers looking for the lead George
[Applause]
boss he's willing to give it up who
changes gears Paul George and Tennyson
nice look there Paul George great John
by the camera crews so unusual other
calls they there's how puts it down
resume it will be clipper ball just a
powerful move there by montrezl harrell
and he was saying heat me on my head or
Lou Williams back out there for Doc
Rivers here's Leonard in attack mode
[Applause]
the Clippers lead 16 to 4 while you step
and hop off his dunk right here it must
be nice to be able to move that
basketball from one hand to the other
hand you're talking about the NBA Finals
teams of the Golden State Warriors
Hispanic town watch the palm we all know
about his hands and then the finish we
receive him dunk for cats with his left
hand
the right hand and makes a poster with a
couple guys who wants to get in there